GOOD MORNING
THIS IS THE S. THE ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE- UNTIL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARE HERE- FIRST OF ALL
WE NEED TO READ OUR NEW POLICY.
POLICY COMMITTEE WHAT WELCOME
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE A
PUBLIC SAFETY HEARING DUE TO
THE CONTINUED STAY AT HOME
ORDER WE'RE PARTICIPATING
PHYSICALLY DISTANCING HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE'RE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT MASS B. WARRANT AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WHETHER
IN IT HERE IN THE IN ROOM I HAD
A VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE. IF
YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM TODAY
AND ROOM FOR TOO LONG TO. WE
CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX
FEET SPACING. THEY'RE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS. EXCUSE ME FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE HERE IN
THE ROOM IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFYING ON A BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND AND I WILL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH A MICROPHONE.
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I
WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC NOT
TOUCHED A MICROPHONE. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HARING ROOM ONCE YOU
ARE DONE TESTIFYING OR RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITOL.
LIMITING INCLUDING LIMITING AB
ELEVATOR USE ONE PERSON AT A
TIME. FOR V. W. R. AND R. T.
WITH. IN ADDITION TO BEING ABLE
TO TESTIFY FROM IN HERE ROOM WE
MAY HAVE SOME BILL WITNESSES
MAKING USE OF ONE OF OUR
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE IN
THE CAPITAL. OUR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS. LOCATED ON
CAPITOL GROUNDS AND IN OTHER
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THOSE WHO WITNESSES WILL APPEAR
ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN
WATCH THE TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OFTHE HEARING ROOM AND
ALSO ASK THEM QUESTIONS. FOR
DIAL WITNESSES. WE WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERN TELL SIR THROUGH
WHICH ANY WITNESS CONTEST ON A
BILL THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS. 877-692-8957
AGAIN THAT'S. 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO
AGAIN THAT'S ONE THREE. ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR OWN TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL AS YOU BEGINNING
THEY'RE BUILT PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ALONG WITH GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE. THE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE BE
ADVISED IF YOU ARE IN A-
WITNESS IF YOU ARE MAY WITNESS.
I'LL PROVIDE TESTIMONY FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL YOU REMAIN ON
A LIFELINE IT WILL NEED MEET
YOUR AND YOUR CALL UPON TO
SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING
PROBLEMS WITH THEM MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE. THREE SEVEN FOUR FOUR
AGAIN THAT'S NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE THREE SEVEN FOUR
FOUR. AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP YOU. I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO
THE PHYSICIAN PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. THANK YOU.
MAN MAN SECTOR CALDERON JONES
SAWYER HERE LACKEY YOUR POWER
CAN DEEP CAM. QUIRK YOU
SANTIAGO WICKS QUORUM IS
PRESENT FORMS OF CREDIT TODAY
GOING TO HEAR S. THREE SIX NINE
HER PRISONERS CAL REENTRY COME
YOU MAY BE. TO BURKE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE HAVE A TEN US
COOPER ON THIS MAY PERSON AS I
SAID THAT SENATOR CARPER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COM LOG IS ONE
OF THE BUT HERE ON THIS BILL.
IN JUST IN SOME. WE HAVE A
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. IT
SAYS WHEN SOMEBODY BREAKS A
RULE AND VIOLATES IS EIGHT
FUNDAMENTAL HARM AGAINST
SOCIETY THAT WE WILL TAKE THEM
OUT OF SERVICES SOCIETY AND
PUNISH THEM BY PUTTING THEM IN
PRISON. THE GOP ARE OUR BASIC-
MORAL CODE IS THAT WHEN SOMEONE
HAS PAID THEIR PRICE. THEY'VE
DONE THEIR TIME THEY PAID THEIR
DEBT TO SOCIETY. THEN THEY
SHOULD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GET BACK INTO SOCIETY IN A WAY
THAT GIVES THEM EVERY
OPPORTUNITY AND TREATMENT AS
ANY OTHER DECENT INDIVIDUAL
BECAUSE THEY PAID THEIR DEBT.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN. THE TRUTH OF
THE MATTER IS THAT WHEN PEOPLE
ARE LET OUT OF PRISON. OFTEN
THEY'RE PUT IN VERY DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES AND COMMUNITIES
AND PEOPLE SEE ALL YOUR GOOD
COMMITTING CRIMES AGAIN WE
LITERALLY GIVE PEOPLE
OPPORTUNITIES YOU KNOW SUPPORT
IF SOMEONE'S BEEN AWAY FOR A
LONG TIME. ALL OF THIS KIND OF
HUMAN ARCHITECTURE OF WHAT WE
DO IS MISSING TWENTY EIGHT
STATES HAVE RE ENTRY
COMMISSIONS. WE RELEASED ALMOST
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND FORTY SOME
THOUSAND PEOPLE A YEAR BY THE
HUNT ROUND NUMBERS ABOUT A
HUNDRED A DAY. AND SO. THE IDEA
BEHIND THIS IS TO KIND OF
COORDINATE ALL OF THE ACTIVITY
THERE'S A NUMBER OF OTHER
PROGRAMS AND OTHER THINGS. BUT
FOCUSING ON THE INDIVIDUAL
BRINGING THE RIGHT PEOPLE
TOGETHER. WE IN FACT IS THE
BILL SAYS- THE THAT WE HAVE. ON.
FORTY THREE THOUSAND RE ENTRY
BARRIERS AND FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOCUMENTARY BE IF WE HAD TEA IN
THE STATE SOMEONE'S GOING TO
TAKE A COMPREHENSIVE VIEW OF
THAT. COORDINATE BOTH RESOURCES
FROM PHILANTHROPIC WORLDS FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FROM THE
STATE GOVERNMENT AND TRY TO
FOCUS ON THE HUMAN CONDITION OF
HOW TO REMOVE THOSE BARRIERS
FOR FOLKS. AND SO THIS IS
SOMETHING IT DOESN'T COST MORE
MONEY WEEK YESTERDAY TO BE A
COUPLE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLRS
A YEAR. BUT TO REALLY
COORDINATE THIS IN A NUMBER OF
GROUPS CAME TO ME YOU SEE THE
SUPPORT LIST ALSO IS THE POLICE
AT. PLEASE DEPARTMENT AND THE
SHERIFF'S IN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES ORDERS ROADS LETTERS SO
YOU'VE GOT A SITUATION WHERE.
IT'S REALLY KIND OF EVERYBODY
COMING TOGETHER AND RECOGNIZING
A PROBLEM AND QUITE FRANKLY
WE'VE DONE SOME PILOT PROJECTS
IN THIS LEGISLATURE HERE AND
THERE. THIS IS REALLY A
COMPREHENSIVE VIEW AND I CANNOT.
I WILL. THIS IS NOT MY IDEA
LET'S MOST BILLS ARE MY IDEAS
THE PARTICULAR CRAZY BUT A
GROUP OF FOLKS CAME TO ME AND
THEY CAN'T I JUST LIKE WOW WHAT
A GREAT I IT REALLY BOTH LAST
BILL LIKE WHICH BEFORE AND THIS
I THOUGHT WAS A GREAT IDEA AND
I'M EXCITED CARRY SO HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTION THAT YOU
HAVE. YOU'VE GOT TO LOOK OF
SUPPORTERS NO TO IT BUT IT'S A
IT'S A REALLY GOOD THING AND
NOW REALLY INFO AND COLD THANK
YOU FOR TO YOU KNOW IT'S
IRRESPECTIVE OF THE PAY IT IT'S
AN PART BUT GREATER IMPLEMENT
IMPLEMENT IT IMPLICATIONS TODAY.
THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YEAH
MISTER LITTLE THE- CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFE. AND JOE. I'M TOLD IS
THE LINE BIG MODEL. YOU LET
MISTER LITTLE IN. GOOD MORNING
SHARE AND LET OF THE- MY NAME
EDWARD. THE CALIFORNIA SHUCKS
AND THE AND WE ARE PROUD
SPONSOR OF THIS THIS LIKE. OVER
SIX HUNDRED TWENTY PEOPLE EVERY
FROM FEDERAL STATE SPEECH YOU
IN THE US OKAY TO MOST RECENT.
INTO EIGHT. HELLO RICK THIRTY
FOURTH. FOUR HUNDRED AND. FORTY
SIX. RELATED FROM. CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES YEAH WE A. LAKE CITY SHE
ARE AVERAGING NINETY EACH. AND
MORE SHOULD HUNDRED AND SIXTY
PROBABLY. OR TWO AGO PAN. OKAY
COMMITTEE RETURNING HOME FROM
IN JAIL HE- ALREADY WITH THE
AND. THIS PANDEMIC ED LAID BARE
THE NEED FOR MORE RESOURCES
THAN THE LACK OF COORDINATION
OF CRITICAL RE ENTRY SERVICES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A CALIFORNIA
MATRIX ISSUE WILL BEGIN TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. CODED
NINETEEN WILL REQUIRE US TO
CONSIDER INSIGHTFUL
PARTNERSHIPS LEGISLATION AND
POLICIES THAT QUICKLY REMOVES
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS TO HOUSING
AND EMPLOYMENT SO THAT PEOPLE
RETURNING HOME FROM PRISON JAIL
CAN BEGIN TO HEAL. AND PROVIDE
FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. WELL TWENTY EIGHT
STATES THE COUNTRY HAVE A
GOVERNMENT INITIATED STATE
BLACK LUNG AND SHE POLLUTION OR
TASK FORCES. THAT WERE DIRECTED
BY STATUTE TO DEVELOP POLICIES
AND PRACTICES AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE BEST WAY
TO HELP PEOPLE RETURN HOME FROM
PRISON YEAH. THE CALIFORNIA
REINSCH COMMISSION WOULD
EXAMINE THE ISSUE AND IDENTIFY
TANGIBLE SOLUTIONS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE DIRECTED A
TWENTY FOOT WALL OUTSIDE AT THE
STATE CAPITOL SHE SHE HAD LIVE
ON THE OVER FORTY THREE
THOUSAND BARRIERS. AND FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOCUMENTED BARRIERS TO
ENTRY. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALONG. IF OPRAH GOOD
MAN THIS IMPORT LATEST
PRIORITIES. IS A CALIFORNIANS
HOME FROM PRISON JAILS AFTER
CHANGING THE THEIR FAMILIES
WILL SUFFER AS A RESULT OF THE
CONTENT OF THE PRESSURE OF RE
ENTRY INSTITUTIONAL RACISM AND
COLGATE NINETEEN. THE LONG TERM
IMPACT INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES. ANARCHIC
COUNTY WILL BE DEVASTATING.
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IS PROUD TO WORK WITH
SENATOR HERTZBERG AND HIS STAFF
AND THIS LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ADVANCE THIS
CRITICAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOT ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. SEEING NONE ARE THERE
ANYONE ON THE TELECONFERENCING.
SEEING NONE. MISTER MISTER
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANYONE
CALLING IN. IF ANYONE WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT IN FAVOR AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO. OUR FIRST
COMMENT COMES FROM THE LINE OF.
LINE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING KAREN NUMBER I
THOUGHT YOU KNOW ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTRE FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW HEAR
FROM LINE EIGHT LINE EIGHT ONE
OPEN. HER CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW HEAR
FROM LINE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GREGORY FIDEL WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SURE THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE LINED UP AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU AN OPERATING BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR AND OR
COMMENT. SEEING NONE. OF THE-
JUST REAL QUICK I IN. I'VE
CLEARLY SEE THE NEED FOR- THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION I DO HAVE
A LITTLE BIT OF A FRUSTRATION
OVER THE TWENTY FOUR MEMBER
BODY THAT SEEMS TO BE QUITE
LARGE. IN ORDER TO BUT I SEE
THE REASON BECAUSE YOU WANT TO
EXPAND THE SCOPE BUT IT IS
GOING TO BE DIFFICULT TO MANAGE
THE PLURALITY OF IDEAS FOR
TWENTY FOUR MEMBERS AND THE
OTHER. IS THE MONTHLY SCHEDULE
PLAYING IS ALSO GONNA BE. IT'S
GONNA TAKE A MAGICIAN. TO BE
ABLE TO- COORDINATE THAT MANY
PEOPLE HAVE THE SAME.
AVAILABILITY BUT- YEAH IDEAS
CLEARLY SUPPORT OF ALL I'LL BE
VOTING YES. ADDITION ALL
DRESSED IN THE CLOTHES. NINE
YOU MAY CLOSE MR FOR YES I THAT
YOU KNOW THE IDEA THE TWENTY
FOUR. ONE MISTER LET TALKED
ABOUT THE FORTY THREE A RE
ENTRY BARRIERS IN THE FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOCUMENTED BARRIERS TO
REENTRY. I'M NOT SO SURE THAT
THIS IS A BODY THAT THAT. MAKES
DECISIONS LIKE THIS HUNDRED
TWENTY MEMBER LEGISLATURE BUT
THAT WITH THE EFFORT IS TO
REACH OUT AND TO GET AS MUCH
INPUT AS POSSIBLE TO UNDERSTAND
THE HUMAN IMPACT. ON PEOPLE'S
LIVES AND BY HAVING THIS
DIVERSE GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT WE
THINK THAT THAT COULD BE
VALUABLE IN CERTAINLY. IN THIS
NEW WORLD ORDER WE LIVE IN WITH
THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY THAT WE'RE
USING RIGHT NOW IN THIS
COMMITTEE I SUSPECT. THAT
HAVING MONTHLY MEETINGS. IS NOT
SUCH IT WILL BE EASIER TO
ACCOMMODATE AND I YOU KNOW
THESE ARE PEOPLE'S LIVES-
EVERYBODY AND I. JUST THINK
THAT THERE'S A SENSE OF URGENCY
IN MY- JUDGMENT ABOUT THIS IN
ANY WE CAN DO. IS A LOT OF
PHILANTHROPIC ORGANIZATIONS WE
TALK ABOUT THAT THAT WANT TO
HELP. WE JUST DON'T HAVE A
FRAMEWORK AND SO. A LOT OF
PHILANTHROPIC ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE A LOT OF MONEY THAT
WANT TO HELP ON THESE THINGS
BUT THIS HELPS. PUT TOGETHER
THAT FRAMEWORK TO MAKE SURE IT
HAPPENS AND SO. THAT'S THE KIND
OF THE THINK ON THIS AND I JUST
WANT TO THANK MY DEAR FRIEND
BLINKY RODRIGUEZ AND BOBBY RDS.
WHO WE HAD THIS MEDIUM RIGHT.
OFFICE WITH A WHOLE HOST OF
FOLKS IT WAS VERY TEARFUL
MEETING. AND IT GOT ME AND IT'S
THIS IS A BIG DEAL AND I ASK
YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL.
ON SB THREE SIXTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER IRAQI
ARE LUCKY ASK OUR CAN. BACKING
HAD. DEEP DEEP I KAMLAGER.
KAMLAGER CORK ONE QUICK I SENT
THE I. WICKS FINISHED.
CONGRADULATIONS MISTER SPURRED
A MEASURE PASSED THANK YOU
THANK YOU EVERYBODY INSIDE.
LOOKING TO ROLL OPEN. FOR FIVE
MINUTES FROM SANTIAGO AND WILL
CLOSE. I THINK THAT'S SHORTEST
REIGNING UNDERCOOKED. IN ORDER
TO YEAH. DANA OKAY WELL NOT.
THE BILL. I'VE ALWAYS WONDERED
ABOUT IT THE DEATH OF THE
QUALIFYING. OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY ONE WROTE. EVERYTHING THAT
COMES CALLED THE BILL CONNECT
HOPEFULLY. ON THE CALL BY. I'M
ON THE PHONE. I MEAN IF THAT'S
OKAY MEANWHILE WITH ALTHOUGH
THE MEDICAL ONE. THREE. WE'RE
SORRY YOUR CONFERENCE IS ENDING
NOW PLEASE HANG UP. RIGHT RIGHT
OKAY.
ON SB THREE SIXTY NINE
THE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I THAT
MEASURE GETS OUT SEVEN TO ZERO
THANK YOU WE'RE NOT CLOSING THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE HEARING.